sur les pelouses du quartier saint-emile
en banlieue nord de Québec les pancartes
de soutien à iriduet m'ont poussé comme
des champignons
personne n'a besoin de convaincre pierre
Davidson de voter pour lui c'est un vrai
gros
il y a 4 ans
pendant des années ce livreur de colis a
écouté le polémiste de la radio de
Québec
ils laissent libre choix au monde aussi
tu écoutes tu choisis c'est vrai ou
c'est pas vrai la vérité sur le
troisième lien le libre choix sur les
mesures sanitaires la contestation
contre le tramway de Québec le chef
conservateur fait campagne pour une
partie de la population qui s'est sentie
sacrifier par le gouvernement
le Parti conservateur considère que le
terreau y est fertile c'est ici qu'on
compte le plus grand nombre de membres
dans la province soit plus de 2000
Québec avait le plus de votes
mais parce qu'on est des kakus on est
des gens qui avons voté pour la
coalition Amir Québec de François
Legault et on est extraordinairement des
soucis on a été trahis
maison de place
du prix
au-delà des purées durs ça prend du nerf
un peu là c'est le cas de Chantal jeûner
ça prend le position fait que s'il y a
de fortes chances que j'encourage
monsieur Diane si on roule plus au nord
le paysage est différent mais les
pancartes restent les mains chevaux
comprend aussi les municipalités de Lac
Beauport ainsi que Sonam et toxbury
c'est quoi votre gros défi de se lancer
tu la main d'oeuvre c'est sûr c'est pas
triste le boulanger à stonam le député
caquiste sortant Sylvain Lévesque et
bien apprécié en 2018 il avait remporté
avec 47% des suffrages un politicien
d'expérience qui ne cache toutefois pas
sentir le souffle conservateur sur sa
nuque tout ce que j'ai promis je l'ai
réalisé ce que les gens veulent c'est
pas seulement quelqu'un qui va chialer
ce que les gens veulent c'est quelqu'un
qui peut régler des problèmes et il y en
a des électeurs satisfaits de la cape
dans le comté je trouve que le CAC a
fait une belle job
puis je pense à ça
parce que le vote antiduelle existe
aussi ici il y a pas de mettre n'importe
qui
surtout son équipe autour de lui puis
toutes ces complotistes ça je peux pas
embarquer avec eux
c'est pas le style de policier qui
m'attire du double encore moins
depuis que je suis qui
à une semaine du scrutin les jeux sont
loin d'être faits chauffe-eau pourrait
basculer d'un côté comme de l'autre ici
jacauderie Charbonneau Radio-Canada
Québec